one of the chief responsibilities of the
us government is protecting the rights
of citizens
but what are those rights
the extent of and limits on rights can
be very complex
that's why we have constitutional
lawyers and supreme court cases to
decide whether the government protects
or prohibits certain activities
but we can make some generalizations
about categories of rights in the
american political system
in this and the videos that follow we're
going to distinguish between three
different types of rights
personal rights
political rights and economic rights
so let's dive into personal rights
this is a really big umbrella that
includes individuals right to decide the
best course of action for themselves
personal rights define the ways that you
should be free from government
interference in your private life
your home
your mind
and your body
you'll recognize some of them from the
bill of rights particularly the first
amendment which protects freedom of
speech and religion
and the fourth amendment
which protects the right of the people
to be secure in their persons
houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures
so what are some of these rights
i've tried to put them into a spectrum
from freedom of body to freedom of mind
and heart
although you'll see that there are lots
of places where freedom of body and
freedom of mind overlap
first there's freedom of movement
this means that you can move to a
different state
or even move to a different country if
you want to the us government won't
force you to stay put
there's the freedom of association that
is to hang out with anyone you want to
there's the freedom to refuse medical
care to be able to control your own body
the government can't force you to
undergo a medical procedure
likewise there's the freedom to have
children
as many or as few as you want
there's also the freedom from government
intrusion into your private domain
also known as the right to privacy
it means that the government can't come
into your home without a warrant or
otherwise interfere in your private life
behind closed doors
there's the freedom of expression
the ability of an individual or group to
express their beliefs
thoughts ideas and emotions
there's the freedom to access education
so people who are school age
have the right to receive a public
education no matter who they are
or whether they have learning
differences
there's the freedom to marry whomever
you choose
and lastly there's freedom of religion
and conscience this is your personal
right to think and believe whatever you
want
the united states doesn't have an
established church
meaning one that the government supports
financially or that citizens are
obligated to attend
some of these freedoms might seem like
no-brainers but people who live in
authoritarian societies don't
necessarily enjoy these same rights
if you've ever read george orwell's
novel 1984
it's a good example of what society
might look like without these rights
in it the government spies on everyone
in their homes
and prevents anyone from speaking out
against the ruling party
but it's also important to recognize
that these rights aren't absolute
many of them have limits and what those
limits should be sparks a lot of public
debate
for example when we talk about the right
to refuse medical care we might think
about vaccines
should people be required to get
vaccines if not doing so poses a risk to
the health of others
what about freedom of expression
should people be able to say whatever
they want or should the government
impose limits on hate speech
the personal rights of one person will
frequently overlap with or even
contradict the personal rights of
someone else
so that's it for this brief overview of
personal rights
in the next video we'll discuss the
political rights of citizens